let's talk next about some incredible
statements from marjorie taylor greene
and tucker carlson both of which relate
to really serious political and media
issues here in the united states first
of all
radical repugnant retrograde republican
congresswoman marjorie taylor greene
complained that white supremacists are
being targeted
when it comes to mass shootings and
domestic terror you have to see this to
believe it marjorie taylor green saying
you know there's all these different
shooters and people doing bad stuff some
of them are black and all this different
stuff and they only want to target the
white supremacists but as usual it's all
in the details listen to what she had to
say and then we'll talk about it bail i
mean not sorry not on the jail on the
bill or this domestic terrorism um new
bill that came out for the department of
justice and jerry nadler was on the
house floor and he was talking about
white supremacy and he was bringing up
the terrible shooting that happened in
new york but totally ignoring the
shooting that happened in california um
that i think involved an asian man that
was a shooter totally ignoring the guy
that drove his car uh black man that
drove his car through a christmas parade
killing people and was a racist himself
completely ignoring ignoring the black
man that did the new york subway
shooting you know these people are all
guilty of these crimes and it's not
about rape it shouldn't be about race um
but they're clearly racist as well so it
so white supremacy shouldn't be the main
target we should be more concerned about
the illegal invasion at the border the
crime happening every single day on our
streets and especially in cities like
chicago we should we should go after
criminals that break the law and not not
pursue people based on their skin color
and and how they vote okay now of course
people aren't being pursued by the
criminal justice system based on their
skin color or how they vote but let's go
through her claims one by one she
mentions the california asian man
shooter that was a shooting at a
taiwanese church in california one
person was killed and five were wounded
it's being investigated as a hate crime
and it was a 68 year old shooter
motivated by the political tensions
between china and taiwan according to
authorities there's no media narrative
there's no political narrative in the
united states
meant to activate or
inspire
any kind of uh tensions between
chinese and taiwanese people living in
the united states you don't turn on fox
news and see
instigative rhetoric about china and
taiwan
such that it would inspire shooters or
whatever the case may be there's really
no conversation to be had there about
american political discourse and
american media
we every once in a while will say oh
what what is china thinking about when
it comes to taiwan but there is no big
media political story that in the united
states would have inspired this shooting
so why would we be talking about it in
the same terms then marjorie taylor
green says well the black man that drove
his car through a christmas parade who
was a racist okay
that's the waukesha christmas parade
attack from november
the driver of an suv plowed through a
christmas parade
killed six people and injured 62.
terrible tragic incident and we know
that the perpetrator used the same car
to hit his ex-girlfriend 21 days earlier
it's believed that the driver acted
alone didn't even know anyone at the
parade wasn't targeting any particular
group of people at the parade the motive
is not equivalent it is true
that the guy was black
it's true that he had a history of
social media posts that were
anti-semitic and advocated for violence
against jews and white people and wrote
positive stuff about hitler disgusting
person no doubt about it there's no
evidence that the incident is related to
the ideology there just isn't any
evidence so why would we talk about it
in the same way
lastly
marjorie mentions the new york subway
shooting who was also a black man that
was six weeks ago that's the 2022 new
york city subway shooting
reportedly uh the man is 60 a 62 year
old black nationalist who put on a gas
mask threw two smoke grenades and fired
more than 30 rounds from a handgun
nobody died fortunately 29 were injured
horrible incident
the believed shooter would sometimes
post
homophobic rants online
misogynistic rants online rants uh
targeting uh blacks hispanics whites all
sorts of different things anti-semitic
believed link to black nationalism great
talk about it talk about it no manifesto
but we've got some of this uh a paper
trail for lack of a better term
uh black nationalism is a tiny movement
there's no political party pushing the
ideology of black nationalism that's it
i mean i'm against any violent movement
but there is no story here
like what happened with the buffalo
shooter where we have seen years now of
a combined political and right-wing
media effort
to talk about this exact ideology that
was in the manifesto lastly marjorie
mentions and we should focus if we
really want to talk about this stuff we
should be focusing on the illegal
invasion at the border
immigrants
documented and undocumented commit crime
in the united states at a lower rate
than domestically born citizens so
by the math of it that is not where you
should focus if you want to stop crime
in the united states because both
documented and undocumented immigrants
commit crime at a lower rate than
american-born
americans for lack of a better term so
it's a weird thing to insert into the
discussion so
why are white supremacists being
targeted well
they're being targeted because law
enforcement
and our intelligence agencies have
indicated this is a major threat
and we quite literally
found the manifesto of the buffalo
shooter where he was parroting the exact
stuff that we've been hearing on tucker
carlson and elsewhere for years now
that's why margaery
one of our sponsors is called privacy
privacy is a totally free service that
i've been using for years privacy lets
me create virtual payment cards with one
click and when i use the virtual card
the money is taken out of my bank
account you can create multiple cards
delete them freeze them set a spending
limit on them let's say i'm signing up
for a free trial and it requires a
credit card privacy will autofill a
virtual card number and then after
signing up i can delete that virtual
card so i know i'm not going to be
charged again something really useful
and very practical or let's say i'm
ordering food over the phone but i left
my wallet somewhere i don't have my real
credit card on me i can use a virtual
card on my privacy mobile app but really
the best part is
you're not out there exposing your real
credit card number so you're not as
susceptible to data breaches and
identity theft privacy is a totally free
service and you'll get five bucks to
spend when you go to privacy.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video